India is said to suspend most travel to
the country in order to control the
spread of the coronavirus the government
announced it will be suspending the
issue of tourist visas to India
beginning midday Friday so if you're
planning a trip to India here's a few
things you need to know firstly no new
tourist or v's ours will be issued till
the 15th of April existing tourist visas
on which journeys are yet to begin stand
cancelled foreign nationals with a
compelling reason for travel to India
need to contact the relevant Indian
mission and the other thing about this
order is that it does not affect
foreigners who are already in India and
those with visas nor does it affect
diplomatic UN official or employment
visas now the restrictions come as India
reported at least 70 cases of the corona
virus in the country most travel related
at least 17 foreigners have also tested
positive the potential for a bigger
spread already has people worried
New Delhi's jumpered market is usually a
popular stop for travel memorabilia now
it lies deserted card maken squarely
blames the coronavirus in six years of
running this shop he has never seen a
slump this big over the last two weeks
his sales have dropped by 80%
tourists both foreign and Indian are
steering clear of marketplaces like this
one for maken taking precautions can get
in the way of keeping up appearances for
the odd shopper who does turn up we have
hand sanitizers for employees in the
shop but we can't wear masks because if
people see us wearing them they'll
wonder what's wrong with us they'll
think let's stay away from him
and if tourists don't enter the shop
what's the point some store owners
desperate for business say avoiding
travel and public spaces is unnecessary
paranoia but with scores of new cases
reported across India this month the
Indian government is taking no chances
India has revoked the visas of all
foreign nationals till April 15th
Indians returning home from affected
countries will be quarantined for 14
days and authorities warn that even
those coming back from other countries
can be quarantined though the onset of
warmer weather means Delhi's chronic
evolution is finally curing up face
masks are still everywhere the surge in
Kiruna virus cases has set off massive
buying of both mosques and sanitizers
pharmacies are running out of stock
shouldn't buy multiple masks and
sanitizers so that others can get them
too many are stockpiling these items but
they shouldn't do that they should think
about the others too the government
evacuates more Indians from affected
countries the total count of cases is
nearly certain to rise in Delhi many
residents are weary and are following
all the protocols a time the spread of
the virus were slim
we'll have to stop going but if people
take the right precautions I don't think
things will get that bad the government
should hand out free masks and install
sanitizer stations everywhere they need
to educate people about this disease
Indians wait to see if and how the
corona virus can be controlled in such a
densely populated country many are
hoping the coming months will provide
better news
so what really are the Indian
government's plans dîablø correspondent
nimisha jaiswal joins me now from Delhi
Nisha how exactly does the Indian
government plan on tackling the corona
virus outbreak well breach the prime
minister has constituted a high-level
group of ministers which is meeting
regularly and reviewing preparedness and
prevention measures across the country
India's focus is on prevention and
especially on the international front
because the 70 plus cases that India has
seen so far are all related to
international travel India has suspended
the visas of all foreign nationals they
are even blocking the entry of overseas
citizens of India who are usually able
to travel visa-free even land borders
are going to be closely monitored
they're actually restricting crossing
over over land borders as well and
they're also going to set up strict
monitoring along these borders every
Indian returning to the country can also
be quarantined and those coming in from
specific affected countries will
definitely be quarantined for 14 days on
the domestic front the Indian government
is trying to reassure people that things
are under control they have set up a
24/7 helpline for anyone who may have
questions about the coronavirus about
this about their symptoms there's also
been an effort to reach absolutely
everybody through caller tunes now every
time an Indian person puts out a phone
call they actually sure and info an
informative piece for one minute about
precautions to be taken to combat the
corona virus and there's also the army
and the paramilitary forces who are
being called in to set up quarantine
facility
is to set up isolation facilities and
testing and medical preparedness for
teams on the ground is also being
insured this is what the Ministry of
Health is continuously put out putting
out especially over the last two weeks
as the numbers surgeon India despite
that nimisha India's health sector is a
notoriously overburdened especially when
one talks about a government hospitals
in the country if their confidence
amongst people that the government can
really tackle this outbreak
[Music]
aggeridge despite the very vocal
environment insistence of the government
that everything is being done to tackle
the Karuna virus we cannot deny that
India's healthcare infrastructure is
notoriously weak that in India has
actually amongst the lowest percentage
of GDP spending on healthcare and the
and the ratio to doctors to patients as
well as nurses to patients it's
terrifically skewed that being said one
of the important things that influences
public opinion on this is actually the
messaging coming out from leaders the
Minister of Health today spoke in
Parliament saying everything is under
control and spoke at length about the
measures that we just spoke about and
the Prime Minister has also been
tweeting saying say yes to say yes to
precautions and say no to panic
so the messaging so far from the
government is that things are alright
and the voices we are hearing on the
street are not yet of serious panic yes
that has been mass buying of masks and
sanitizers but people seem to believe
that precautions will do the trick you
have to know that the cases are still
under a hundred in India and already
these restrictions are being deployed on
travel and all of those other
restrictions that have been imposed by
the government so people have confidence
so far but it would be interesting to
see what happens over the next two weeks
especially if the caseload goes up the
corresponding official just 4 in Delhi
thank you very much for that
[Music]